Ladies and gentlemen, I am here today to
show you how I maxed out my funded
account in one session on NQ using
nothing but developing value area and a
two-day composite. It was that simple.
It was a great session and I was able to
max out my funded account with using
nothing but developing value area and
understanding of auction market theory
and the two-day composite. Uh, one thing
I want to note real quick is look how
old this 2-day composite is. So, I was
trading on July 28th into the night of
July 29th. Uh, this 2-day composite is
from May 3rd, I believe. Yeah, from May
3rd. And the reason why I want to show
you guys this is because it doesn't
matter how old your composite is.
Doesn't matter if it's 2 days old, 5
days old, 5 months old, 5 weeks old. If
it's the only area that has balance, the
only relevant area of balance, then it's
going to be a relevant compos composite.
And obviously, as you can see here,
like look at look at the reactions we
get off this composite.
So obviously, it's a relevant composite.
[clears throat]
And when I when I looked at this
composite before I started my session, I
I could deter I could defer here. Sorry,
I could understand here that we were in
a rotational we were rotational within
the two-day balance here. So that that
is important to understand as well is I
could see here that we were rotational
within this two-day composite. Uh so to
start off, we took a small scalp here.
So we started at the one extreme up
here, standard deviation two. we shift
back in a developing value area and we
see a strong
shift in momentum to the bearish side.
Uh we fail to make new highs. Uh we we
failed a push above the daily VWAP.
Daily VWOP holds as resistance and then
we see a shift out of the developing
value area here. I took this trade here
without actually waiting for a pullback
um any sort of return, any sort of test
of the developing value area low because
I'm comfortable with taking a trade and
closing it early before I hit my stop
loss or or even at break even and
looking to re-enter a trade. Um if if
you're not comfortable with doing so, if
you're the type of person who who's
going to take their trade all the way to
stop loss, then I wouldn't recommend
doing something like this. I I would
recommend waiting for the pullback. I'd
wait I recommend waiting for the retest
of the value area low of the developing
value area or whatever whatever area
you're looking at and then taking the
trade. But because I'm comfortable with
scratching my trades, uh I'm going to
enter here as soon as we fail to make
this new high above and then we shift
back out of DVA here. Uh final TP here
was very very easy. Um I I just I just
took a final TP at the next extreme of
standard deviation 2.
If you want to stick with the rotation,
if you want to just take a super small
scalp and stick within the two-day
rotation,
um you're more than welcome to take a
final TP here at the two-day value area
low. That's actually where my first uh
take profit was. So, I took a partial
there and then I closed here at standard
deviation 2, which was roughly about
five R at the end of the trade.
Next, [clears throat] we can see here on
a higher time frame
that after we shifted out of the two-day
composite, we shift back in. We see a
clear shift back in, strong push up, big
momentum on the buyer side, and it
leaves it leaves a slight imbalancer for
us. And along with that, when we shift
back into the two-day composite, we're
also shifting back into developing value
area here. And once we're shifting back
into the composite and we're shifting
back in a developing value area here,
it's kind of confirming to me that we're
going back up to the next extreme, back
up to the next extreme within our
rotation. Um, so this is where I did
wait for more conf confirmation. I did
wait for a pullback before entering. I
wanted to see that the two-day value
area low would hold. I wanted to see
that we would stay within developing
value area and we weren't going to break
back out and continue lower. I needed
further confirmation which is why I
waited for the pullback. And once I saw
that our two-day value area low is now
support.
Developing value area low is now
support. I I'm I'm comfortable to enter
here. So I entered on this little
pullback. We see here I think on a
shorter time frame there was a pullback
on the one minute. Where are we here?
Yeah. So, it was actually right here on
this pullback here is where we entered
on on the one minute time frame. So, I
entered on that pullback there.
And final TP. Simple enough. We're
playing a rotation of the two-day value
area high. So, I am TPing final TP at
two-day value area high. First TP very
simple as well. Uh I took a TP at the
daily VWOP here for about we'll say
three three and a half hour R and then
final TP here at value area high for
about we'll say five and a half sixR
there. Uh, and I think it's very
important to to understand why I took
this as my final TP and I didn't decide
to go back to the next extreme up is the
reason why I did that is because we're
rotational in the two-day value area
here. And you you can I mean you can go
to the next extreme if you want. Uh you
can even go to the developing value area
high here if you wanted. Uh but this is
the safest TP here. We're rotational
within the 2-day. We know we're
rotational in the two-day. Anything else
is kind of just a guess. So, this is why
I decided to take my TP here. And we do
see
[clears throat] a shift out of the 2-day
value area. And now, a lot of people
would see the shift out and say, "Oh,
we're breaking out. We're going long."
But I don't see that here because first
of all, we're still in the developing
value area. Developing value area is
holding as resistance. We're we're
failing to shift out. We're failing to
make new highs. Uh clearly two tests
here as resistance. So I don't see a
breakout opportunity here. I don't see
enough time and space spent above the
two-day rotate the two-day composite for
me to say, okay, we're breaking out here
and we're going longer. And also
another point is when you when you make
your hypothesis for the week or for the
day, uh you you you decide if you're
neutral, bullish or bearish for that day
or for that week. And I was not bearish
in any sense here for NQ, which is why I
didn't look for any longs here in the
first place. But everything developing
value area here showing me is that we're
we're not going further in. We're not
we're not breaking out of this range
anyways. So this is where we took our
biggest move here. This is what kind of
just finalized everything here. I took
this big move and I said, I'm done for
the night. I maxed out my my funded and
now I can I can sleep easy. And this was
here. So after we see this this slight
shift out of the value area, we see a
big push back down in. We shift back
down in and then we see a reaction off
this daily VWAP. And when we shift back
down into the value area here,
we see an imbalance is left behind. That
imbalance is left behind.
I don't want to enter this short until
this imbalance is filled here. Um, so I
I waited until we get a fill of this
imbalance here. Uh, which happened I
guess right here.
So, we got the fill of the imbalance.
It confirmed to me that the two-day
value area high is holding in fact as
resistance. And then we entered here on
the on the bearish candle that was going
back down.
[clears throat] And I went for a little
bit of a bigger move here.
I went for the yearly VWOP here just on
a higher time frame. I was bullish on
NQ. Sorry, I was bearish on NQ, excuse
me.
And the yearly VWOP was sitting pretty
close to here. And I thought, okay, I'm
going to take my TP1 here at value area
low regardless at about 3.3R.
And if we fail to shift out towards the
the the yearly VWAP and we shift back
into developing value area here, I can
close the trade and regardless, I'm
done. Regardless, I've maxed out my
funded and I can sleep easy. But so I
took my first profit there. Uh,
obviously here we failed to shift back
into DVA. If this held here, I'm done.
I'm closing the trade. But obviously it
didn't. It just filled some more
imbalance up here and continued back
down to the next extreme at yearly VWAP.
And we closed this trade here for about
8.869R,
something like that. I don't know. I
don't remember where it was exactly, but
nonetheless, [clears throat] all I did
here for these three trades was watch
developing value area. See, are we
shifting within developing value area?
I'm looking to see where the energy is,
where the momentum's going. Um, are the
are the are the sellers more aggressive
here? Are they winning here? Are the
buyers more aggressive here? Are they
winning here? And I know that we're
rotational within this 2-day composite.
So, as auction market theory says, don't
assume anything until proven otherwise.
So, I'm assuming that we're staying
rotational here. So, all I did for these
three trades was use my two-day
composite, played the rotation, and I
use DVA to help me confirm that the
rotation is existent, is still existing,
and I use it to help execute my entries.
Super simple. Three trades within one
session, 9R, 5.9, 5.2. maxed out my
funded in one night and all it took was
a basic knowledge of auction market
theory, composits, balance, acceptance,
rejection, and my developing value area.
And that's it, folks.
>> [snorts]